as we begin the hour
i want to bring you
an update
on our vice president
sometimes it's unclear where she is at
any given time which actually led us to
create
a brief segment a little theme song
almost for the vice president
[Music]
well she's actually
in france
on an official
government trip
there was a clip of her today
in france speaking with
some people i guess at some sort of
scientific facility and it sounds like
she starts to
almost put on a little bit of a
french accent
which was a little cringy here it is in
cut 15 making the rounds today with us
in government
we campaign with the
plan uppercase t uppercase p v plan
and then the environment is such that
we're expected to defend the plan
even when the first time we roll it out
there may be some glitches and it's time
to reevaluate and then do it again
zipline
there is zipline
you leave it there for one more week
she'll have a beret a long cigarette
ziplan
it it
it's just
a walking talking embodiment of veep
who happens to be actually the veep
and to her credit
and this is actually perhaps a bit of an
achievement she is in europe she is in
france remember this back in june
she was asked about why she had not gone
to the border as the border crisis czar
doing a great job obviously
and part of her very strange answer to
that question with nbc news
was this cut 20. do you have any plans
to visit the border at some point you
know
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole this whole this
whole thing about the border we've been
to the border we've been to the border
you haven't been to the border
i and i haven't been to europe
and i mean i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
i'm not discounting the importance of
the border
that was so strange
that was so awkward at the time and of
course we got the laugh we got the laugh
in there at her little joke about having
not gone to europe we've been to the
border he said bill you haven't she's
like well
i haven't been to europe
well now she's in europe
so that must be very exciting for her
on jimmy kimmel's show last night that's
if you're unfamiliar jimmy kimmel
is a democratic strategist
and part-time comedian and he's got a
show on one of the networks that loses
to greg gutfeld every night got failed
on cable
kimmel on broadcast and he loses every
night to uh greg gutfeld which is fun
jimmy kimmel's just sort of um kind of
just sleazy
uh quasi-comedian guy who gets a lot of
his talking points literally written for
him by chuck schumer that was actually
revealed
but he'll come out and do some of his
little indignant monologues about
republicans he gets his quote-unquote
facts
from chuck schumer's office so he's a
democratic strategist also a
self-appointed pope uh you know he he
wants everyone to take his
moral decrees very seriously
as he should i mean he made
his career
as a guy who sat around drinking beer as
women jumped on trampolines right this
is this is someone who can absolutely
preach from on high to all of us so this
democratic strategist and part-time
comedian had some thoughts about kamala
harris it's been uh not a great couple
of weeks on polling
for president biden or for vice
president harris we talked about how
harris was uh just about as unpopular as
biden slightly less popular as a matter
of fact in this suffolk usa today poll
and jimmy kimmel was upset about this a
fellow democrat you know is under attack
not
not garnering rave reviews from the
american people so kimmel decided that
obviously the problem
is the american people cut 14.
um
besides sexism and racism the obvious
reasons why her approval rating is so
low well you know she's at negative 23
in that poll underwater by 23 points
biden is statistically the same
underwater by 21 points last time i
checked joe biden is a very white man
now is it sexism and racism that
explains his poor approval rating or is
that only for his similarly unpopular
vice president who he's put in charge of
some big things like the border which is
a disaster i know he's saying the vice
president doesn't do anything maybe
that's part of the problem
she's tasked with things and then
doesn't do them or doesn't do them well
so it's sexism and racism
that explains why harris is unpopular
but fill in the blank for why biden's
unpopular i'm sure it's probably more of
the same
that because they see sexism and racism
as a built-in excuse always and forever
couldn't possibly be
the failures of the administration
and the leaders of that administration
and the two most high-ranking government
officials in the entire united states of
america
i know
that's it's a big difficult thought for
jimmy
so he's got his answer there it's sexism
and racism i actually
do have a thought though
kind of like a follow-up question for uh
for jimbo here
which is
why is it
that kamala harris when she was running
for president remember she called joe
biden a racist
during that campaign
remember that one
she was running for president she wanted
his job not her current job
she was such a bad candidate
for president
that she didn't even survive the
candidacy did not even survive
to iowa
she dropped out before a single primary
or caucus voter even showed up
and i know this might be difficult for
jimmy to remember if he even knows this
stuff maybe get a little quick refresher
tutorial from chuck schumer
but that was a democratic primary that
was all his team their side
and by his team i mean you know the
democrats the side you know that he
embodied for example when he lost to ted
cruz in a one-on-one basketball game
something he should never live down
hilarious
it was his team his party the
enlightened non-racist misogynists
supposedly in their party who were so
unimpressed by kamala harris that they
rejected her forcefully enough in the
polls that she didn't even bother to
come to iowa to get humiliated and lose
badly by her own size voters maybe
that's also sexism
and racism jimmy i don't know
but the proof was in the pudding
in the democratic primary
so my theory is maybe her approval
rating
is a tied to the flailing president
tied to the failing administration
in which she is a major part
tied to her
poor execution
and poor results
on one of the most high profile items in
her portfolio
immigration and tied to the fact that
she is an insufferable phony and it's so
obvious
perhaps jimmy kimmel has a sort of
knee-jerk
understandable defensiveness
when it comes to fellow
insufferable phonies that could be part
of it
or
it could just be that he has uh
sympathies or has a soft spot
for people like kamala harris who will
literally laugh at anything
it's the guy benson show we'll be right
back
you